MICHAEL. PLEASE BE ADVISED AN
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S FOR STUDENTS BE MADE AS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED OF
MANCHESTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
HERE FLORA. GRAYSON KAMLAGER
HERE'S- MY MATHIS BURKE SILVA
PROBLEMS HERE RIVAS WORKS HERE
GRAYSON YOUR CHANCE AND WE HAVE
A- WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE
INSURGENT THAT SIR MOTION
BECAUSE- SECOND. MOVE MUST READ
THE SECOND ALBUM IS AS PUSH THE
ROLL CALL HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO HI SO I
FLORA FOR A FIRST I REYES AND I.
THANK I MAIENSCHEIN. MATHIS AYE
AYE QUIRK SILVA PROBLEMS. BUT I
PROMISE I RIVAS WORKS TIME
WORKS I PASSED THE MOTION
PASSED- AND WITH THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THAT CONCLUDES
OUR BUSINESS AND WAIT A MOMENT.
FIRST SUMMER ACTION COLLEAGUES.
SO WE HAD A CONSENT AGENDA OKAY
AND THAT WAS IT HELLO SIR I ON
CONSENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BURGER. WE HAVE THANK CHAIRMAN.
RULES CURRENT.